well guys welcome back to the quarter
cast uh nico has some amazing
technology where it only captures his
voice
nothing else um you can't tell right now
but there's actually a metal band in my
backyard that's practicing
yeah and separate was practicing in his
backyard
um what a what a reference man yeah
thanks
uh they got me through law school wow
i'm impressed today guys we got nico
perringer
hello we've got christian burgerstrom
greetings and we've got ren wykman
there he is that googly-eyed guy
right there hey how's it going everyone
uh guys i'm sorry
i missed uh the last podcast because
that topic was
of conversation was right up my alley
they're all about moral paradoxes um i
mean just
that that sort of like existential stuff
i
i really enjoy so um all right jake then
just
just the one word yes or no answer would
you kill baby hitler
no that's what we came to also that's
what we all ended up coming to
that's my ultimate answer uh there's
there's actually a good response in the
comments for you they said
it's not your job to make that call um
by you taking upon that moral dilemma
you are
creating an immoral situation same
question of
if there's garbage in the street and you
pick it up is it now you're garbage
the answer is yes yes it is yeah if you
put it back on the ground that's
just as much your phone i caught jan on
camera doing that and he picked up trash
he's like is this not mine i was like i
think it is he's like no
[Laughter]
yep um wow speaking of trash
on the street oh i think there's some
trash
in the form of punk humans who have gone
down there
to tag to make their to make their
presence
known to the world um so first and
foremost
uh nate we're we were talking about some
things before this podcast started nico
said hey
they've been tagging more down here and
that is talking about vandalizing
and vandalizing too now before we even
get into that topic
quick roundabout who here
at any point in their life has
vandalized or tagged something
well define vandalism because i've never
tagged anything with spray paint
i think my my most probably best example
is putting like a sticker on a public
thing probably but that's probably the
furthest i've got
technically that's vandalism totally
it's low-key
but um
really random you're a no i mean i think
i've like peed on a building before but
like does that count
uh that was probably in college for you
yeah it was nico
no it was yeah it was last tuesday i
never vandalized anything
really christian no i mean yeah maybe
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait like a public power
nico i know
but that's probably my extent there was
that one guy
who moved into hunter street oh yeah
eight years ago
he was okay that's aggressive that's
like
revenge though that's not really
vandalism what happened what happened i
mean
technically but it's not really
christian asked what happened this is a
podcast i'm obligated to tell a story
yes let me take my gum out of my mouth
okay
all right gum not gun um
all right guys
um so this dude moved in and like
super super aggressive like probably
some disorder or something like that i
don't know
i mean at a certain point you can
quantify anything as like a mental
disorder but he was an [ __ ]
through and through so whatever i don't
know what you know
you want to put on
needing to go to the hospital i mean
maybe yeah you need to go hospital but
also nuts isn't like
he was just really mean um like numerous
things like so we remember we're doing
uh the light warfare video for freddie's
channel um
zoom in yeah wait this is so this is how
far back it was i think i'm zooming down
the street at like 60 miles an hour this
is like
a dead-end warehouse street and we're
all in the middle of the street he
doesn't slow down he just swerves around
us almost runs over all the camera gear
and we're like this guy's nuts and
there's another time when like he was
down the street like on itself on his
bluetooth like yelling into it
and sam's looking out the window at him
and he looks at this and he's like what
it sounds like
i can look at you it's like you wanna
fight and sounds like come up here
there's a time when he was walking up
into the building and uh
one of steve's uh handymen was working
and the guy
called him a wet back um you know and
other racial slurs
um there's one of the craziest stories
was uh
so dez was a guy used to live in the
building and des
uh turns a corner from santa fe under
hunter so he turns onto the street
and this guy he's at that corner waiting
to turn out of the street
he makes eye contact with dez he throws
his car in reverse
and he proceeds to drive with dez
holding eye contact not looking where
he's going while driving backwards just
glaring at dez
so imagine you know you're driving down
the street another dude's out the side
driving backwards
staring at you like it's so reckless
even he can easily kill somebody
so anyways of course he in my theory
based on the damage to his car he
rear-ends a semi-truck
if you're if you rear-end a semi-truck
you're an idiot
yeah it's like hitting a school bus
they're big and they're bright yellow if
you hit it it's your fault you're an
idiot
stacking up into a barn yeah
so he parks his car in front of joel's
loading dock doors so joel owned the
poodle parlor which is a film
uh location at the end of the street and
he runs it as a business and so he's
loading doors to load film tracks in and
out so the guy parks his
bunk car with the damaged front in front
of one of jewel's doors and doesn't move
it
and by this point we've had all these
issues with the guy like all these
conflicts have happened he's an [ __ ]
like we're telling jay who's the guy
who's subletting him like this guy's got
to go
and jay of course doesn't do anything um
so
joel comes to us and he goes look the
guy's car is parking for my door
you guys want to help me out you guys
want to you know
tell him to move it that's i've told him
to move it he's not moving it like we'll
help you out
so so we had heard about something
called ninja rocks which are basically
the ceramic of a spark plug
so you know the the hardness scale like
for example
the only thing that can scratch diamond
is another diamond
um well tempered glass is very very hard
but tempered glass is also under
internal pressure because of how it's
made
and so if you scratch tempered glass if
you manage to disrupt the molecular
structure of tempered glass tempered
glass explodes just like uh those rupert
drops or whatever they are those little
they could drop yeah yep so tempered
glass is basically the same thing
so uh a ninja rock basically you get a
spark plug and set ceramic on a spark
plug
and you can uh you can break it up into
little pieces and it's just ceramic you
know it's you know
crunch it with the brick isn't like that
and you get little chunks anyways you
just
lob one of those a tempered glass and
it'll cause the tempered glass to
explode so this is what we had heard
and then we went and proceeded to do
experiments
and uh used to say when we were done
that car had no more windows
yeah for that i remember you guys
telling me about that like right after
it happened i remember
coming down to hunter and seeing that
guy a few times and like
same thing happening like having him
walk by me with like these
just aggro malicious
looks and everything um
i wonder what happened to him i wonder
if he's in jail or something
because i don't know man how long can
you go around like that
before before somebody kills you
yeah you meet the wrong person you're
angry to the wrong person
you you do something uh to somebody else
and then
you know you you get caught for it
obviously like
yeah there's only so many
and like this is just like walking
around like swearing once in a while
this is like aggressively
like assaulting people yeah it's like
this is crossing the line this is all
yeah this is like i just wanted to be
clear this guy's not just like you know
shouting [ __ ] once in a while like he is
assaulting people he was putting
people's lives in danger on the regular
like yeah
hopefully the windows breaking his car
is a wake-up lesson but
i will see i mean who knows i haven't
heard that i've heard from the guy
obviously i'd have no interest in ever
hearing from the guy
i talked to him yesterday he called me
up we caught up
okay so we'll go ahead and qualify that
as
as uh reduced vandalism
punishment yeah be punished
uh okay well this sure makes me feel
like
the odd man out here because i i've
certainly
vandalized and tagged things in my day
not that it was a good idea not that i
even thought it was a good idea at the
time but the motivation for doing it
was i think just such that uh
you're like well i don't know how
rebellious you guys were as teenagers
not very okay but i think that's
that's maybe what it comes down to i was
i was very
sticking to the man uh when i was a teen
and of course you were
i just wanted to have fun that was me i
don't know if that's like
i didn't necessarily do it for f i mean
we did it for fun too
but we never did anything serious we
never like
burned down a building or something but
like um
you know there was a time there was this
they they built this bridge
and it was in that fresh concrete and we
and we tagged it but we didn't take this
we didn't tag the side facing the road
because we didn't like actually want
people to see it
we just wanted to spray paint a wall um
you know did that uh
that's so much different than like
somebody's brand new shop front and then
going through the spray paint candace
yeah across all the windows yeah we
never did anything like that
i mean that yeah that kind of stuff's
happening all over the place around
hunter
and on hunter i saw that one guy uh
spray painting a swastika on the
buildings across
the street from us one time and then
like the next day at the news
yeah the truck showed up and the woman
reporter was like
really kind of pissed at us because we
were not being uh
helpful yeah remember she was like do
you think there's a lot of like you know
anti-semitism and like nazism happening
and growing you know in the dark corners
of the neighborhood like no it's clearly
just some dude trying to like get people
to
be pissed off like you and she's like
you're not giving me the sound bite i
want yeah she also asked if i was drunk
too because she she asked me like well
what do you look like
i don't remember she's like you don't
were you drunk i was like whoa
i was like flying by him on my one wheel
to go to my car it was like like 9 00 pm
at night and i didn't even remember
i just remember him uh turning around me
like hey what's up
like that's weird why are you saying
hello i didn't think about it until the
next day when uh the guy was
uh like hey we have you on camera like
talking with him
what did you say what did he say and i
was like what are you talking about
good guy yeah yeah probably thinks he's
just doing it to get people to finally
paint over the graffiti
so city is supposed to paint over
graffiti you know and keep it from
getting you know from spreading
guys we've got a great solution to all
the graffiti
in la we're gonna go around with red
spray paint we're
to take swastikas over all of it that
way people will
actually cover it up with paint i have
been tempted to do that by the way
like i was also going to think about
just doing giant like dicks and
everything
just like look i'm tired of this
graffiti sitting here take care of your
buildings guys
i think even in irony it's a very bad
idea to
ever make a swastika because that's why
i was going to do big penises
yeah that would be better yeah they
would like like comment bubbles like
they'd be talking about the graffiti
let's talk about the motivations here a
little bit
you're a young you're assuming you're a
young person right you're not really out
there tagging it
in your mid-30s at least if you are
you're doing it
you're doing it either as a professional
street artist or you need to re-evaluate
your life decisions
uh so let's assume you're you're a young
person
out there you're gonna tag you're going
to tag
the the lighting building on hunter
street
why lighting quick quick quick
roundabout rent why would
you have the answer to this one screen
so well
i actually caught somebody taking that
building like he wasn't taking it he was
doing a calligraphy art piece on the
door
um and he was like look if they don't
like it they can paint it over but i
just want to make something beautiful
here and like
i like that kind of stuff you know like
the random acts of art thing
i think that's what we talked about our
graffiti graders video but the people
that go around just like slap their name
up on [ __ ] that clearly like people
don't want them to
like somebody takes a nice time
finishing a building and somebody goes
and scratches their name in the window
it's like [ __ ] you man
like actually i shouldn't mention his
name there's a guy though
he takes everything downtown what'd you
call him
that's his tag name aids yeah
with a z yeah okay now but now that we
mentioned him we gave him we gave him
that notoriety he's been looking for
screaming into the voids working for him
what can you do
okay so there you go christian's hitting
it on the head are they just screaming
into the void
or well i mean yes
but i feel like definitely part of this
too is that you know the area is
becoming more expensive it's becoming
gentrified businesses are moving in
and there's generally an attitude of hey
get out of here is my place
you guys are ruining it right yeah [ __ ]
the man
that's that's the mentality yeah like
what do you think
i mean i don't know i just because
you're not you're not you're not shoving
it to the man
or whatever you're you're
inconveniencing what you think you are
because you're an ignorant young person
you're like you're say you're 17 years
old you're 16 years old
you go out with your buddy you're you're
drawing all day at school and you hate
school
because it doesn't teach you anything
about tagging so then you
you know so then you go and you tag
because you're like hey well they have a
business i don't have a business
they're the man i'm not you know
because you're you're further down on
the on the societal totem pole
and so anybody that's like
not you know you and your friends and
the music
that you listen to and whatever other
cultural influences you take on as part
of your personality
are all you reject it all i don't know i
guess
part of me is like it's hard for me to
relate to that because i just like
never did that and i don't really have
any desire to do that but the other
the other part of me gets it like i'm
like
it's it's i mean there are far worse
things they could be doing
to other people just to you know show it
to the man or whatever like
like you're sure you're gonna paint on
something you're inconveniencing a
private person
who has to go and now paint it up
because the government's not gonna do it
and i i don't know it's
it just seems silly all of it to me it
is
a lack of empathy yeah i think yeah
that's what it comes down to it's just
like
but you know figuring for others in that
kind of way it's just like
why if society's not doing anything for
me slash has failed me then why should i
care about society you know
it's kind of the general consensus i get
from it yeah
but yeah so that's so you know that
that's when you get into the particulars
of like who it is
and then it's like well has society
really failed you or you just feel that
way
et cetera et cetera um there's also some
gang stuff that goes on
in and around hunter street every day
that guy who dropped by today oh
a guy dropped by today you were there
weren't you no no nico we were waiting
on nico that's why we were locked down
oh okay yeah
so getting into the studio was a whole
problem today because
uh the electronic locks died so we had
to wait for nico to show up to open it
with his one lock so like i got two
calls of
hey can you just throw the keys down i
don't live there anymore
what do we do i was like oh shoot that's
a real problem we have now
i should probably make copies of those
keys
whenever all else failed yeah so
me and spencer it's uh sam nick
uh christian and myself we're all just
chilling out in front of the studio
um acceptably socially distance of
course
uh and this guy rolls up in a in a bmw
rolls his window down his seat is like
really like leaned back
and i forget what he says is like hey he
goes do you know where i can get 500
units
and sam goes what crack like
he goes 500 units and he looks at nick
he goes you know what i'm talking about
and looks like and sam goes are we
talking about drugs what and he goes
yeah dude i need some bud i need 500
units
and then we were literally like oh
there's a dispensary down the street
like you go there
like sam literally gave him directions
he goes yeah go right on santa fe
left on sacramento and there's a big
green buddha place there
he goes no i'm looking for more like the
like wholesale he wanted wholesale
he wanted to become a dealer it ended up
just being a laugh because we're like oh
yeah dude
none of us are going to help you out
with that he's looking
he just rolled up and was just like yo
you know where i can get 500 units and
sam was just so like what
are you cause like he was like no no
he's like
making eye contact with each of us and
and i'm just smiling and i'm going like
no dude i don't know what you're talking
about and then like literally
like looks at me like are you talking
about drugs
like he's like i don't know can we talk
about guns or taxes like what are we
talking about here
we're talking about like apartment units
like you're looking for a 500 unit
building
they just started on a bunch of
different unit measurements and was like
you could have been talking about
anything man this is why you always
label your units guys
i've never heard anyone refer to weed
that way but perhaps he's talking about
such large quantities that i know that's
what it was yeah he's talking about like
wholesale or whatever he wanted
he was using a different word instead of
grams i think there are like uh
there's at least four grow ups on hunter
street well that's what we also said
the main joke was you could probably
just walk up and down the street and
start knocking on doors and you'll find
somebody
yeah i was like man i was hoping to
avoid that i guess that's what i'm going
to have to do
he pulled him in the street and parked
yeah dude it's actually like
kind of it's kind of concerning how many
grow ups there are on hunter street
because
as shown by that butane explosion that
happened in la two days ago
it's grow ups are not always the most uh
they don't always follow osha
regulations if you know what i'm saying
guys i'm kind of worried that there's be
a fire on the street at some point
because of shitty electrical wiring
and then like and there goes our studio
i mean remember when we
got the studio how bad the electrical
wiring was yeah and it wasn't even a
grow up
yeah that was just like yeah we just
wanted to put our computers up
and we had to rewire and not even rewire
we had to add wire and do some rewiring
to the whole building
you guys want to have another story time
yeah all right so
uh probably about three maybe four years
ago
there was a power outage and all the
lights went out in the studio
and you know we gave it like half an
hour to an hour and like power outages
happen especially in that part of
l.a um just because they've all since
gotten back up batteries for every
computer
yes yep they've come in handy so many
times
yeah like there's a lot of like hiccups
in the power um and part of it is just
like there's a lot of construction that
was happening in that neighborhood so
you know you'd have to take the
electrical down for a minute and like
reroute things and
that stuff would happen but like this is
like a true power outage like it goes
out and doesn't come back on for
5 10 15 30 minutes and we're like well
you guys want to play ttt we spent the
rest of the day playing
tdt with nerf guns it was a blast we had
a great time um
but what had happened so you know across
the street and down the street a little
bit
some dudes have moved in they were doing
uh extractions basically where you
um you know you make weed vape uh stuff
and um rather than paying their
electrical bill they decided they should
just illegally tap into the electrical
mains for the city
so they don't have to pay the money to
grow their weed
um and sure enough they pull too much
power and they blow the transformers
and end up you know taking up power to
the entire block
yeah and like first off that's such an
[ __ ] move like all the businesses now
are without power
because these [ __ ] can't pay their
electrical bill for their
the stuff that they're making money off
of you know it's like you're going to
screw over all these other businesses on
the street because you guys are too
selfish
that's criminal recklessness or at least
criminal at least for criminal
negligence
what's the difference between
recklessness and negligence recklessness
is when
um you knew that it was wrong but you
did it anyways
and negligence is when everyone else
in your same position would have known
that it was wrong
but you're just not that smart and you
didn't realize it
i mean to me this is thievery is it not
uh well there's thievery against this
utility company yeah and then there's
recklessness and reckless endangerment
and then obviously if it causes a fire
and you have arson or whatever that
damage is that property damage
because it's reckless it rises to the
level of
being of guilt as if you did it anyways
so that's not good for them no
but needless to say that got the fbi
involved and they uh
shut those guys down and they tracked
the illegal wiring to another unit on
the street and
took all the plants out they didn't no
warrant by the way
because you know if those guys can play
dirty the fbi plays dirty
they just went in cut the locks quietly
took all the plants out and left
and that was that um they're good for
them
screw those gummies but uh the fvi just
took their whole crop
and all their gear they just took it
that was it we're like we're not going
to charge you but all that stuff is arms
now
[Laughter]
um yeah welcome to the real world guys
this is how law enforcement actually
operates when they're not trying to tell
you how it works in the newspaper
um but you know that's how it goes this
is the game that they play but
it you know and then so there's this
fire in la like two days ago
um there's an explosion downtown so if
there's an
extraction company and and of course
they don't have all their flammables
stored in the same speed
weed extraction yeah they see those food
maybe these are both
like um what's it called uh
they're making e-juice i don't know hash
oil
um i don't know if it was just swede um
it might have been multiple
you know just all the babies is there it
was some sort of like
uh burnable oil yeah yeah and they're
using butane to extract it because you
can
you know you shoot butane through the uh
through the buds and then you
collect the resin from you know the
gathers from the butane which dissolves
it
um and of course you know they're not
following any sort of regulations when
they're doing it a fire starts and
all their butane isn't stored in a safe
spot and you know firefighters are
trying to put it out
it all lights on fire it blows up 11
firefighters go to the hospital
all because these [ __ ] are trying to
be cheap and
dude that stuff just grinds my gears man
it pisses me off
yeah especially when you're well so
yeah no it does um the question that i
wonder is like
given the gray area of legality with a
lot of this stuff
i wonder if they're disinterested
in seeking uh
is to establish like industry standards
for fear of of um you know
criminal criminal prosecution
because you know like again
the entire marijuana industry is still
playing the game
of it's illegal federally but it might
be legal in your state
yeah so is that gray area
causing people to be like
well i mean obviously you get a certain
type of person who's going to work
at a at a weed facility right like
they're probably
at least if chinatown market has taught
me anything
and this is around and the surrounding
not that chinatown market's a weed
manufacturer but like they're those
types of guys let's be honest
um so you know
chill 20 year olds still hit 20 year
olds and they they wear that they were
like the tie-dyed overalls with one
slinging off and then they cut them off
at the ankles and they wear the dress
shoes with the tall socks and like the
stocking hat tilted to the side
you have like the long blonde hair
that's not cut sticking out from
walk up and down the street you know who
i'm talking about yeah really
yeah nothing wrong with that but that's
that's the type of person that works
there
um so you got that type of person
and then you also got this this whole
thing where it's like well if i'm a weed
manufacturer and say i'm making hash oil
or i'm making
whatever juice or whatever and i stick
my head too
far up too high
you know is that government gonna is the
is the fbi gonna come in and are the atf
gonna come in and chop it off
or can i like reach out to my other
you know can i make a chain can i
franchise
[Music]
because i i feel that's a different type
of game you play once you get to that
level
you know right so you got to go to your
like you're getting but those are the
types of people that are going to come
up with regulations at the same time
right when your head gets when you stick
your head up that high that's where you
need to be like doing campaign
contributions and going to your city
council meet and greets your you know
your dinners and like
schmooze at the mirror and that kind of
stuff that's no different than you know
meeting with your agent and like
schmoozing some producers at a dinner
it's exact same thing just it's a
different industry
right but you gotta be able to play the
game yeah
so okay so the person says say there's
somebody who's looking to franchise in
the weed game and then they go and do
that and they'll say they're doing all
those things but they're not
they're not paying attention to their
factory operations
somewhere somebody got somebody got
negligent
at least oh yeah and then accidents
don't happen because they're being
responsible
i've been thinking more and more about
this uh anytime someone gets injured
99 of the time somebody gets injured
it's because you it's because somebody
who is
either at fault or partially at fault
for the accident itself wasn't paying
attention
or they they were paying attention but
they were
doing something stupid like you're doing
something
you're paying attention but the
circumstances in what you're doing it
are
not good and so that's 99
i feel like and then the other 1 is like
you know mechanical failures and things
that are out of human control
we've also heard the term you know risk
mitigation and you know a lot of people
think that that means avoid risk and
that's not necessarily what risk
mitigation means
you know accidents and bad things happen
not because usually one thing goes wrong
but because many different things have
gone wrong
um and they shouldn't have you know it's
like let's say let's say somebody dies
because a you know heavy object falls
off a shelf hits in the head and they
die
you know and they're working at a
warehouse it's like well risk mitigation
they should bring their hard hat it's
like
yes but there's actually a lot of things
at play
you know the thing that was put on the
top shelf shouldn't have been put there
shelves from a bit that high
shelves should have had the guards you
know in place the box should have had
this kind of stuff in it
uh the person worked too late and they
were tired they should have been you
know they should have had their break by
then like there's a whole stack
of things right at any point you know at
any point had you followed
regulation or you know the rules it
would have averted
the crisis you know it's not one thing
that happens it's it's a whole chain of
things and you make it through each one
of those making the shitty decision
until you get to the end
and then the accident happens and that's
always stuck with me one of those things
have to go wrong
for this guy to die is that a perfect
segue into coronavirus
or well actually before we go into that
before we leave this whole like
you know the jungle that is hunter
street now i want to talk about what my
car was broken into
okay so at the beginning of the pandemic
my car was broken into
you know this is the perfect time for me
to screen share
christian will you give me shareability
you should be able to
i like how it thinks christian shirt uh
the background behind yoda is also
getting filtered out
just depending on every now and then
it's like baby yoda's looking at the
at the sky are you able to share the
screen you should be able to yep
here we go i just got to be very
descriptive for our audio listeners
i will all right so this is hunter
street
um okay guys we got a full camera feed
so you see this big truck parked in the
bottom left corner yeah that's
one part of the thievery gang that uh
hit the street and robbed my car
i'll jump for a little bit here so i
spoke to the cops i came and they make
it they made a police report like i have
this footage like cool
come and pick it up on your sd card and
i've called them twice
they've never come by they have no
interest and that also pisses me off
like i have
the dudes right here who did it
i have their license plate numbers
because my neighbor woke up from his dog
barking and took down all their license
plate numbers i even typed one of them
in
into google and the truck shows up i
have all the registration information of
course the person
what yeah either you know the
information the person is private why
have you not filed a detective's report
i did we
they don't give a [ __ ] look at these
dudes there they are
these are the [ __ ] that robbed my
car man like these are their trucks
these are their
vans i want to save their license plate
number online but i have a thing against
witch hunt so i'm not going to do it
but look at these guys just walking
around
stealing [ __ ] with a cargo van yeah
it's a whole opportunity for that guy
you could take that guy out real easy
once yeah oh jesus you can barely even
walk
man it's just like they got this big
argument for some reason
like apparently the operation wasn't
going super smoothly
yeah none of them have masks on they're
just gonna have masks on
oh and you can see so if i go back one
here there's a shadow of my trunk on the
right there this is the dude in my car
he got into the trunk somehow
so he broke into your new car yep and
there he's got all the fruity pads that
had my trunk on top of my stroller
thankfully my one wheels weren't in the
car but he stole our stroller
he broke my freaking lcd screen on a
dashboard
like out of all the things to break like
the lcd screen it's expensive
you're telling me that you have
the car all the cars
i have their license plates their
license flights their registration
numbers and you've
called the lapd this is the i'm
you've called the lapd and told them
that you have this information
and that they've committed grand larceny
and they literally haven't sent out a
detective
to do anything about this correct grant
larson he's a
felon that's three to five years yeah
look at this dude there he is grabbing
all my [ __ ] right there
on the right corner of the screen and
he's going to put on the stroller and
now if he goes
dude he's he stole my spike ball kit
he's just
rolling down the street with your
stroller
there it is there it is there's a spike
ball kit right there you see that you
have that yellow circle
yes
you've had so much trouble with this car
how long have you had this car
uh i don't haven't had any trouble i had
it for one year this is the only issue
i've had with it oh no wait no except
for the guys
that print renegades also slashing my
tires because i parked the parking spot
can we talk about why that is why how
could that possibly
be what what's that how could how could
that possibly be how could you possibly
have this much information give it to
the proper authority
and then have them not do anything and
then also
second question what are what are you
expected to do in light of that
dude i don't know man i mean part of it
like this is beginning the pandemics i'm
sure the cops are a little bit you know
preoccupied with other things but it's
probably because you know
occupied with finding people for trying
to run their businesses
dude it's because it's work man it's
because it's you gotta
sit there and you gotta do work and it
doesn't just get done without you and no
one wants to do that [ __ ]
it's bureaucracy work no one wants to do
work
it's like i got this report i can go
talk to the guy
i can get the video i can write these
reports
i can run the numbers and then i'm going
to have the guy's address i'm going to
make a warrant
go out there serve the warrant i might
have to deal with a confrontation
or i could just not
you know do you honestly why would you
why would you get into the profession of
detective or police or law then yeah i
mean that's supposed to be your job
maybe they got bigger fish to fry they
don't
look this whole pretty heavy fish right
here
there's like 25 000 law enforcement
officers on the lapd
yeah and there can be this is a pretty
big fish and you got all the information
you need
this is a this is a this is a this is an
open and shut
they call it you get these guys you
arrest them
you put them you get them do a plea deal
they surf they serve
they serve a year and a month and
that's it and it's lesson learned yeah
dude i have i literally have the license
plate number for this pickup truck right
here
looked it up and its registration is
current i didn't even use a fake license
plate
like we could run it we can get the
dude's name and go to this house and we
could we can ninja rock his windows
i'm not gonna say we should do that but
that's not a bad idea it's not a bad
idea you want to hear about the time my
car got stolen
yes yeah all right i'm going to stop
screen sharing
wait hold on let's just one last thing
these guys get into a fight right here
i was going to say that there's about to
be a confrontation in that moment yeah i
guess this guy's just doing a shitty job
of being on lookout or something like
that
and like they start yelling at each
other
and they're like yeah because it looks
like he's asking him to get out of the
car
yeah i find i'll take over driving the
cargo van
look at these bunch of wankers
they're on the street for so long just
sitting here yeah they're
just out here exposed to whatever
so this is 2 30 in the morning right yep
and then finally they get out of there
and that's the end of that oh my god
whoo dang here the card
car stuff yeah yeah sorry tell us yours
foreign i've had a lot of stories in
this podcast
so back in college i had this crappy old
uh
car it was a mazda626 i loved it it was
amazing
uh but i i was
staying at my girlfriend's house for the
night and this is back when like i
didn't store anything of value in my car
so i never locked the doors um and i was
like this is a crappy car no one's gonna
like
like there's nothing to steal like not a
big deal in here
uh except for the fact that that mindset
had a complete disconnect from the other
mindset which was
i need to store a spare key in the glove
compartment
of my car key to your house or to the
car
to the car in the glove compartment
of an unlocked car dude bravo
like you know you weren't gonna trust me
it was too completely different like
this is a brilliant thought
this is also a brilliant thought
together they are the worst thought
uh so of course naturally one morning i
woke up
to go to class that morning i had an
eight o'clock class and
my car is gone i was like that's weird
that's
really freaking weird it i didn't clue
in that like my car had been stolen
um i later found out that it had been
stolen no like
wait wait wait wait i filed a police
report because i
very quickly figured out that it was
probably stolen
what's up jake how long between walking
outside and seeing that your car was not
where you parked it to realizing that it
may have been stolen
i don't know a couple months like no i'm
playing
what the heck you so just for two months
you were just like oh yeah i don't know
where my car is at
minutes sure it's fine like it was
i ended up showing up to class at the
end
of that class it was it was my calculus
class and i told the professor that i
missed class because my car had been
stolen
so at max an hour later
right um but so i yeah i filed a police
report and i was really
bummed about it because it was like you
know i was like 19
or so i was in like a sophomore in
college
and uh it was like you know as a college
student if you have a car
that's like your biggest thing in life
uh
and so now i had it gone and so i was
kind of really depressed and
a week and a half goes by and i get a a
call from the police saying that they
found my car
and i couldn't believe it because at
this point i was starting to give up
hope that it was ever going to get found
again
so i immediately uh jumped in my
friend's car
and he drove me out to where uh they had
found it it was just on the side of the
road
uh it was probably just some
some person i don't want to say like a
homeless person because i just simply
don't know but
uh they'd gotten into my open they're
like
oh hey look at this the car is unlocked
check that out check the glove
compartment what's in what's the value
in here oh it's a key
this looks like the car key i'm gonna
try it oh snap
the car turned on what a lucky day
you know three or four in the morning
whatever they uh and it was a stick
shift
and one of my girlfriend's roommates at
the time recalls waking up to hearing
someone stalling their car like four or
five times
early in the morning so there's
obviously some dude who didn't know how
to
like uh drive a stick shift car they
made it like you know
like 5-10 miles away something like that
okay so let's break this down
it was a homeless person looking for
money to buy drugs
and they went into your car and they
found the key and they drove off with it
for a joyride something like that but
they did take
everything that was in my car so i had
uh and this is what made me realize that
my thought process of there's nothing of
value in my car was so
wrong because they took the entire
center dash
console they ripped it out they took
like the radio and whatnot
for a few couple get a couple bucks out
of that but the worst of it
was and they also like took my cds they
i had like this metallica cd that had
just come out it was like
death magnetic or something like that
they had taken that cd i love that cd
that's when you got pissed oh dude no no
i had just gotten back from a trip
up to seattle to visit my uh my aunt
and she had homemade jam that she had
made from berries she'd pick
on her property her house uh
i forget what kind of jam it was but
he didn't take the jam he ate half of it
and left the other half so wow that's
i'm like well i can't eat the rest of
this now i don't know what's in it
i'm just picturing this homeless guy
after just
finishing going on a joyride opening
this
[Laughter]
and just like eating half a jar of jam
and being like i'm
full putting it in the driver or the
passenger seat
getting out of the car and never
returning
i think the most portland story i've
ever heard
yes this was in portland oregon i forgot
to mention
uh wow yeah there's a couple
there's a couple um like kids
in downey uh you know they're like early
twenties
they're not usually they're not like i
don't know they're just
they're just looking for for money and
stuff you know they're just they're just
hood rats
and they come through and they they
check doors and they occasionally they
steal people's cars like that
and yeah it's not good
i do always lock my car from then on
yeah ryan mike i do have to ask one
question though what is the logic about
of keeping a spare key to the car in the
glove compartment of the car
i honestly don't remember because the
idea would be is you need that spare key
if you get locked out but if you're
locked out you're not getting into that
glove
no the logic doesn't really make sense i
think i remember having a good reason
for it because
because you never locked your car door
it was because i never locked my car and
i was worried about losing my keys yeah
and i wanted to have that key
that would be didn't have like a lock
box underneath the tailpipe so you put
it in the glove compartment
yes the key to the car is just sitting
in the glove
trust me i know how dumb this was i had
my car stolen it was a big wake-up call
but you got the car that's the same car
you took down to l.a isn't it is yeah
little white mazda yep wow
i eventually replaced the radio in it uh
i had it for many many years until
some uh truck driver in l.a was on his
phone and rear-ended me and completely
caved in
the bot the back of my car that was the
very morning we
shot the first day of video game heroes
versus
superheroes when you dressed up as
master chief
i was like 30 minutes late for that
shoot because i just been rear-ended
yeah i remember that
wow what does it all mean guys
what does all this mean i mean it means
we're all living in a simulation
well you know what's funny like you know
i just i just moved
this is my new office and i just was
outside the other night and i was
looking at the stars and
i was thinking about how petty like
the things that humans argue about is
or or the things that we like are so
important you know you got the guy
who's angry all the time at hunter
street and he's like
causing near-death incidents with people
because he's
who knows what's going on here you've
got the guys who come down in the cargo
van
and they just literally start breaking
windows and taking things
out of people's cars you got the kids
who come by and tag
you got the guy who who's looking for
you know just
whatever he can find that that stumbles
upon ren's car
and then you know he's out somewhere in
a field eating jam
it's so ridiculous when you think about
it all it's so ridiculous
anyway that's that's my conclusion
i'm just glad i'm not living in hunter
street anymore it was getting really
stressful
dude yeah i mean i
i love hunter street in this guy i got
stories for days but like dude like
i grew up down the street because they
didn't want to put spend the money
uh for air conditioners put giant
industrial fans on the roof instead
they put like six of them in a row and
i woke up one morning and like what's
that noise it sounds like
like my microwave is on and i go in the
kitchen my microwave's not on
go in the front room i still hear it are
my neighbors vacuuming
and then the noise doesn't stop and it
goes on and on
and on for the entire day into the next
day
and into the next night eventually i go
up on the roof to figure out what it is
like maybe there's construction
happening or something like that i don't
know
and it's those fans and they're all
cranked up to like maximum power
and it's really just
[Music]
they were resonating at the same
frequency of the building
so the entire building was shaking from
these
fans because i also separately was like
what the hell is this it was
driving me crazy because it like it was
an annoying noise because it was the
actual building
emitting the noise so i went up to the
roof and i walked across all the other
roofs
uh where we did like the nerf drone
fight with jan and all the way to the
end there where it kind of starts
sloping up and there's this big huge
like
fan things and that's when i realized oh
it's these things making noise
yeah no regards for their neighbors no
regards for anybody else
you just put you know a sound barrier up
and it wouldn't have been an issue
didn't they burn out yeah so thankfully
karma you know came and caught them
um because when you are that much of an
[ __ ] you know noise
is a form is a good way of knowing that
energy is being dissipated
through a system and when your fans are
making that much noise it means there's
a lot of energy
going into the structure of your fan so
sure enough
about five or six days later like i'm
i'm getting
very close to like i'm you know typing
in like what corrodes aluminum so i can
start like pouring it into this fan
[Laughter]
i don't have to do it because some of
the other starts to be like uh
sound coming from those fans of course
it's loud i'm like i can live with that
assuming that it gets worse for the next
day or so sure enough the next day
silence so those fans
burned themselves out i think what
actually happened
the fans are probably not supposed to be
that loud i think they wired them
incorrectly
i'm sure you know it wasn't permitted or
anything like that and i think they
overdrove the voltage into them and the
fans are
cranked way too high yeah they probably
yeah they probably just the motors are
probably
way overcranked yeah they burned out in
a matter of days
yeah i do remember seeing guys up there
working on them
the fans are still there now but they're
much quieter oh they're just
they finally got the noise down we
should we should
hire somebody to just
live at the studio and document
everything that happens on that street
really really that was me i mean i had a
camera i documented it i just showed you
guys footage of my car getting robbed
like what else do you want this is the
result
nothing like lick look you you you've
laid a great foundation nico but what we
need to do is we need to pay some
some kid to go in there and like live
there and like
literally go to every building and shake
hands with everybody and be like hi my
name is
you know steve jupiter and i live here
and
i'm you know i'm just this is where i
live so i'm i'm a
video creator and then literally have
that person like
fall create portfolios on every
person and business activity on the
street and then
come up with like actually follow and
track stories of what happens there
yeah telling you there there could be
there's there's gold in them hills
to do it let us know in the comments
needless to say now i have sidewalks and
trees
and sweet old armenian neighbors
this is my third night at this house and
just wait till you have to apply for car
insurance
you're gonna have to pay more really why
is that because glendale is the highest
uh
most expensive uh car insurance place
and wow
really in the world i don't know if it's
the top but it's definitely up there
because there are two things
a very high rate of accidents and a very
high
density of expensive cars in glendale
there are tons of
uh bmw mercedes uh bmws lexuses
a lot of expensive cars and they love to
get wrecked they love it
they love the correction you're gonna
notice if you haven't noticed it already
is how often you will see
uh someone in a bmw
mercedes jaguar or audi who is
predominantly persian
or armenian armenian against them but
this is just predominant the most of
them
most of the people that are racing down
the streets of glendale in those types
of cars
there is a more probable than not that
they will be one of those
types of individuals
and often like looking like they just
got out of the gym
[Laughter]
i will say i hate to like fuel like
stereotypes but oh they're fun honestly
mike's living in glendale for four years
okay so yeah so not you know you know
obviously goes without saying
that there's plenty of exceptions to
every stereotype
um but it is kind of funny to think
about because you know even family guy
made a joke about it
in that one episode yeah
they make jokes about everything but
anyway yeah i will say when i was moving
in
um one of my neighbors met the guy he's
really nice he
lent me his dolly his hand dolly for
moving furniture
um but they're having a graduation party
there's one of those things like
hmm there's like 20 people at your house
and like half of them are old
are you you know what's going on right
now right i mean
i get it like if you if you're not super
concerned you've been socially isolating
but like
there's a lot of old people at that
party so
they're like they're like look we made
it through a lot worse
yeah i mean you're right we're not
worried about that
it's like we like to gamble
no glendale's awesome though i think
you're gonna love it up there there's
like
there's a ton to do there's a ton of
different types of people there's really
good food
uh there's a ton of places to go out um
and it's close to the studio
it's close to where you can hike it's
close to
the valley um so
yeah i think that's why a lot of people
live there which is and also
you know people are always going through
there which is probably
why there's so many accidents because
every time my sister-in-law lives there
and every time we go up there it's just
the traffic is crazy
yeah i just i think there's some uh
public transit there like train like
metro train
because there's yeah i don't know if
they're yeah there's not one up there no
because i remember how i like i
my card gotten wrecked and so uh i spent
like six months just riding my onewheel
to the studio every day
but this is before the xr that could do
all the range so i was having to go to
the train
and take the train to downtown union
station and then ride the rest of the
way
but it wasn't like metro it was like
amtrak
you know it was like like you you buy
your ticket to the seat you
put your stuff in the overhead bin and
you sit on the train
yeah the train train yeah train yeah not
just taking it on and get out because in
pasadena where i live now they actually
have
proper like you know the gold line the
metro uh that comes through and that's
awesome it's easier
quicker
well guys um you know i guess
conclusions
in the comments below please if you know
the meaning of it all and you know why
angsty teens uh draw graffiti
and you know why um you know people
steal cars and
slash people's tires and eat half a jar
of jam
need half a jar of jam let us know in
the comments
and also um two podcasts ago
uh this is a this is a worthy of report
here two podcasts ago we told you guys
about uh a little bit more about the
details of our website ren what is that
this is a picture
you haven't changed a bit my friend
okay so two podcasts to go we told you
guys about what we're doing with our
website
um we told you guys about how one
subscription on the website is
equivalent to more than a thousand
youtube videos and
a bunch of people a bunch of troutons
went over there and signed up for the
site um
and uh that was incredibly inspiring
um and uh i've told you guys we're going
through the process
of uh hiring a few more editors
um you know that is it that is in part
to serve the ends of the of the
new site um and uh
as part of that a new feature that's
being introduced
right now it's available on web and it's
gonna be soon on android and then after
that on ios
uh chromecast works oh really
yeah so if you have chromecast at home
and you want to get
and you're a member and you want to get
the corridor site videos in full 4k
on your tv and you don't want to go
through youtube's
janky compression um you can do that
also there will be um the
live stream feature is already working
on web but it's going it's it's ours
also already working on android
uh and next week it's going to be on ios
and
uh if you guys don't have the app for
your phone whether that's i
android or ios download it and give us
some feedback
because we are fast approaching the
public launch of the site
and we want to make sure that those are
in ship shape
so please let us know and
yeah also we will be notifying you guys
when we have our patreon
live streams and website live streams um
more yeah and that'll be actually next
friday we're gonna do another live
stream
um now everybody even if you're just
subscribed to the website you can also
join those streams
we're working on notifications but
there's also uh push notifications when
you're on the website when we're live
there's a little we're live buttons
so we didn't have those last time we got
them now
yeah we got them next friday at 5 00 p.m
we'll be doing a live stream on the
website
so we are we are uh
looking at your guys's comments we're
looking at your guys's feedback that's
coming through the site we
are super valuable yeah um so and
clint is has joined us in ren's in
wren's plane
so drinking a nerf dart
he is thinking
[Laughter]
what's that christian next friday at
five pacific next friday at 5 p.m
pacific we will be
live on a big zoom call on the website
one final announcement the podcast next
week we have a special guest mr
carmichael
david carmichael um we are going to be
filming that podcast on wednesday and we
are planning to release it on thursday
so
if you are wondering about how to get
your your earbuds
on the nicest human in the world
consider tuning in
uh consider subscribing you have to
title that podcast
the nicest podcast the nicest podcast
with the nicest guy the nicest guy
in the nicest forum on the nicest
platform
yeah all right awesome
good stuff gentlemen as always guys
thanks again and uh
until next week thanks for listening
yeah that was a lot of fun
thanks for listening to all my stories
of getting robbed
and then flirting with vengeance yeah
this is definitely cathartic jake was
like have you ever vandalized anything
and he was like
no of course i wouldn't do that what
melts aluminum and i'm going to pour it
all over this building here
yeah yeah yeah i have i've thought about
dark fantasies about vandalism i didn't
even mention
the things that you told me about your
ideas for how to get back at print
renegades we didn't even discuss it
next week next week
[Laughter]
oh boy anyways
i'm dark and mysterious guys you
wouldn't know it by my demeanor
[Laughter]
but inside it's all painted
yeah thanks for listening everybody this
is a blast
i'll see you guys in the next one